vivient d'arriver à T Taganrog.
IlIls ont roulé toute la nuit
popour traverser en Russie.
D Des femmes, des enfants
épépuisés.
MaMais visiblement soulagés
d'd'êtrtre ici.
"L"Les forces séparatistes nous
onon dit d'évacuer immédiatemen,
paparce que l'Ukraine prépare ue
agagression majeure" dit Tatian,
"e"et on entend les tirs depuis
dedeux jours."
LaLa Russie leur a promis un to,
etet un peu d'argent dès s leur
ararrivée, mais ce matin c'est
lele chaos. Certains sont dirigs
vevers des trains, mais on ne
sasait pas où on va dit Pavel.
D'D'autres passeront la nuit ic,
dadans un gymnase improvisé
enen camp de réfugié, ou Vladisv
esest seul et désespéré.
- - Il est donc parti de Donets,
paparce qu'il ne veut pas revive
lala guerre comme en 2014.
CoComme tant d'autres, il n'a ps
ququ'un sac et quelques vivres.
"J"J'ai entendu les sirènenes qd
jeje dormais, alors on a pris
leles documents et on a fui"
didit Ruslan, 8 ans, qui n'allat
plplus à l l'école deux jours,
paparce c'était trop dangereux.
- - Avec d'autres, cette femme
fafait la file devant la Sberbak
popour récupérer les 10 000
roroubles que la Russie leur ofe
popour la transition , c'est
l'l'équivalent de 160 dollars.
"M"Merci Poutine, merci la
RuRussie" dit cette femme.
- - Mais tout l'or du monde
nene pourrait consoler Valentin,
ququi fond en larme quand on
lului demande où est son mari.
CÇa c'est le cas de beaucoup
dede femme ici, leur mari est
rerester pour se battre, suite
a a un appel à l la mobilisation
gégénéral, à D Donestk et Louga,
ilil y a beaucpuo d'anxiété.
LaLa tristesse et la peur
sese lisent sur leurs visages.
EtEt elle fait mal.
"J"J'ai laissé ma maison, mon mi
etet mon fils ainé aussi, c'est
lala guerre vous comprenez".
- - On aura croisé quelques homs
cocomme Vladimir, qui dit êtrtre
paparti avant l'appel
àà l la mobilisation parce qu'il
nene veut plus participer à
cecette guerre absurde.
RuRuse ou pas de la Russie,
popour justifier une invasion
dede l'Ukraine l'évacuation
dede milliers continuent,
lala souffrance de ces famille
enen cavale est réelle et pourrt
dudurer longtemp.
I Ici Tamara Alteresco
R Radio-Canada, à T Taganrog,
e en Russ